I couldn't believe it when I saw in this
last state of the union speech how many
members of Congress are walking around
with a big abortion pin on their suit
jacket right incredible that they feel a
need to support that to show that they
support
women's rights to make medical decisions
in the context of a supreme court and a
Republican party that is hell-bent on
attacking that right a shocking that
Democrats would show that hey we support
women's rights
not just advocating for but celebrating
abortion on depend on demand without
exception
all the way up until birth or even after
birth normalizing and fantasy we've seen
this in places like New York and in
other states what so this this is
straight up untrue